wir sind alle sehr traurig über das
wahlergebnis vom sonntag das kann uns in
keiner weise zufriedenstellen da gibt es
auch gar nichts zu beschönigen und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir jetzt
einen neustart hinlegen ein neustart wo
wir auch viele viele dinge anders machen
werden um das vertrauen der wählerinnen
und wähler wieder zurückzubekommen es
ist so dass wir momentan sehr
unübersichtlichen gemenge lage sind das
heißt wir haben die situation dass es
keine klare mehrheiten gibt dass es
mehrere optionen gibt eine koalition zu
bilden
es ist so wir stehen für gespräche
natürlich selbstredend bereit wir stehen
für gespräche bereit mit der fdp und
auch mit den grünen aber natürlich auch
nicht um jeden preis das heißt da sollte
jetzt auch in dieser woche mehr klarheit
geschaffen werden wie es weitergeht weil
dieses land auch den anspruch darauf hat
das also entsprechend schnell regiert
wird und dass schnell eine regierung
gebildet wird ich gratuliere ganz
herzlich alexander dobrindt ja gerade
zum vorsitzenden der csu landesgruppe
gewählt worden ist und wir werden jetzt
gleich gemeinsam in die fraktionssitzung
hinein gehen wo wir die
fraktionsgemeinschaft dann entsprechend
bestätigen werden zwischen cdu und csu
das ist mir persönlich sehr sehr wichtig
dass das auch so harmonisch und gut
klappt das ist eine sache sich auch
daran weil wir sehr gut zusammenarbeiten
alexander dobrindt und ich und danach
ist es so dass wir unsere arbeit
zuordnung beschließen werden wir werden
danach dann auch die fraktion
entsprechend konstituieren und werden
dann auch einen fraktionsvorsitzenden
wählen
alexander vielen dank wir kommen jetzt
zum ersten mal zusammen nach der
bundestagswahl nach einer sehr sehr
schwere niederlage für die union und
deswegen erwarten wir dass auch in der
gemeinsamen fraktion natürlich über
dieses thema intensiv noch diskutiert
wird wir haben uns heute sehr viel zeit
und raum genommen für diese diskussion
und diese debatten die kombiniert
natürlich mit dem
möglichen sondieren für eine
regierungsbeteiligung
zusammenhängen wir haben die
bereitschaft dass wir diese sondierungen
auch annehmen wenn sie dann kommen
sollten sage aber auch ausdrücklich dazu
dass erstens aus diesem wahlergebnis
kein automatischer regierungsauftrag
abzuleiten ist zweitens wir uns
verantwortung nicht entziehen und
deswegen selbstverständlich für
gespräche zur verfügung stehen
drittens allerdings für die gemeinsame
fraktion klar ist dass wir uns mit
unseren inhalten nicht entfernen lassen
und
keine koalition um jeden preis annehmen
wollen sondern es geht darum dass die
cdu csu fraktion
mit ihrem kern ihren inhaltlichen kern
bestand hat auch für die zukunft auch in
einer möglichen koalition
mit anderen parteien deswegen werden wir
auch genau darüber diskutieren wie man
solche sondierungen wenn sie dann kommen
entsprechend auch ausfüllen kann
wir werden heute den
fraktionsvorsitzenden wählen ich habe
ausdrücklich auch darauf wert gelegt
dass das zu beginn der konstituierung
einer neuen wahlperiode in der fraktion
stattfinden muss die fraktion muss
handlungsfähig seien sie braucht einen
klaren auftrag an einen vorsitzenden wir
wollen ordnung und dazu gehört dass wir
heute auch entsprechend wahlen
durchführen
ich glaube ich darf das sagen dass ich
derjenige bin der dann an der stelle
auch die wahl durchführen darf in meiner
funktion als erster stellvertreter und
vorsitzender der csu im deutschen
bundestag bisher liegt mir meine
bewerbung vor ralph brinkhaus
weitere bewerbungen im laufe der sitzung
kommen kann man nicht vorhersagen das
ist möglich aber
aktuell liegt mir keine weitere vor
vielen dank kommen wir nun zu ihren
fragen frau schweizer vom mdr bitte
herr brinkhaus wenn sie sich zur wahl
stellen heisst das sie stellen sich für
ein jahr zur wahl oder sind sie auch
bereit einen kompromiss zeitraum zu
tragen und wenn ja warum dient das dem
innerparteilichen frieden oder wie ist
das jetzt verhandelt worden die beiden
parteivorsitzenden werden gleich einen
vorschlag machen und in der tat es läuft
ja dann schon über die medien das wird
ein kompromiss sein es wird deswegen
kompromiss zu einem das auch ganz klar
zu sagen weil es darauf ankommt dass wir
auch sehr geschlossen sind und so werden
wir dann in die nächsten monate
hineingehen werden dann schauen wir
alexander dobrindt das gesagt hat ob für
die sondierung hinkriegen oder nicht
hinkriegen wie wir uns als fraktion
insgesamt aufstellen das ist ja auch
eine aufgabe wir haben viele neue
mitglieder in der fraktion wir müssen
uns um orientieren weil die fraktion
auch anders geworden ist und da gibt es
sehr viel zu tun in den nächsten monaten
und das wollen wenn ich denn dann
entsprechend vorgeschlagen und gewählt
werde wir beide dann gerne gemeinsam
machen vielen dank frau sievert von
focus online ihre frage bitte
ich habe eine frage an herrn brinkhaus
und einer an herrn dobrindt erbringt aus
ich habe jetzt die frage von frau
schweizer akustisch nicht ganz
verstanden aber ihre antwort hat meine
frage nicht beantwortet deswegen
versuche ich es noch mal wieso ist man
sich heute erst oder jetzt kurz vor
dieser sitzung darüber einig geworden ob
sie für ein halbes jahr oder für ein
ganzes jahr fraktionsvorsitzender werden
und die frage an herrn dobrindt sie
sagten gerade wir brauchen ordnung im
zitat ende ist das geordnet wenn armin
laschet alleine gespräche führt an denen
sie noch nicht teilnehmen oder nehmen
sie daran teil
also es ist so dass es ja durchaus
mehrere lösungen gegeben hätte jetzt
also wie der fraktionsvorsitz zu
besetzen ist also sowohl vom zeitlichen
ablauf als auch vom personellen
tableau und ist es gut und das zeigt
auch dass wir handlungsfähig sind das
obwohl es da er augenscheinlich
unterschiedliche meinungen gab also wir
in der lage waren lagen kompromisse
herzustellen und das zeigt auch das cdu
aber auch cs muss jeder daran
interessiert sind jetzt ruhe
reinzukriegen und auch verlässlichkeit
reinzukriegen damit wir auch
entsprechend der gesprächsfähigkeit
haben
sondierungen kann nicht einer alleine
führen
sondierungen können übrigens auch
parteien nicht alleine führen sondern
sondierung geht nur mit der fraktion und
der fraktionsführung gemeinsam auch
deswegen ein guter grund das nicht nur
die csu ihren vorsitzenden heute gewählt
hat als landesgruppe sondern auch die
gesamt gemeinsame fraktion ihren
vorsitzenden wählt kommt deswegen ja wir
legen wert darauf dass wenn sondierungen
wenn sondierungsgespräche gibt dies
ausdrücklich unter beteiligung der
fraktion stattfindet und mit beiden
parteien cdu und csu gemeinsam alleine
ist dies nicht möglich die letzte frage
an herrn blank von der deutschen presse
agentur
herr brinkhaus noch mal genau auf den
punkt sind sie bereit sich auch für
sechs monate wählen zu lassen und die
zweite frage ist nachdem die csu in sehr
großen wert darauf legt dass die union
bis ende der woche spreche ich ist das
heißt auch personen und personal
sozusagen klar hat ist armin laschet für
sie der verhandler für die cdu bei
möglichen verhandlungen über eine
jamaika koalition also armin laschet ist
der parteivorsitzende der cdu deswegen
ist er der geborene veranlagen genauso
wie dann aus der markus söder auch ist
und genauso wie das dann also die beiden
vorsitzenden der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion das heißt ich
dann hoffentlich als vorsitzender und
alexander dobrindt als chef der csu
landesgruppe
und ich glaube das ist der kern es kann
keine sondierungen geben ohne die
fraktionen wir haben da auch eine
positionierung wir gehen da sehr sehr
offen wir gehen da auch demütig rein
weil wir wissen wie unser wahlergebnis
ist aber wir werden auch nicht alles
mitmachen weil wir unser markenkern
natürlich auch er retten wollen und
dabei auch durch bringen wollen
es wird gleich ein vorschlag der beiden
parteivorsitzenden geben ich bin sehr
daran interessiert dass wir heute eine
harmonische sitzung haben dass wir eine
harmonischen start haben und ich glaube
der muss sich jetzt also auch ganz ganz
viel unterordnen denn es geht jetzt
darum dass wir zusammenhalten es geht
darum dass wir zeigen dass wir dieser
schwierigen situation gut klarkommen und
die schwierige situation ist nicht die
besetzung des fraktionsvorsitzenden
sondern die schwierige situation ist das
wahlergebnis vom sonntag meine damen und
herren herzlichen dank für ihr interesse
wir sehen uns ja heute abend nochmal wir
werden uns die woche nur öfters sehen
dankeschön
ja damit ist es also klar es wird heute
keine kampfabstimmungen geben man hat
sich im vorfeld geeinigt was vernünftig
ist damit man sich hier nicht heute
zerlegt das war ja von dem ein oder
anderen erhofft oder erwartet worden und
in der tat gibt es verschiedene
interessen in der cdu vor allen dingen
aber auch in der csu und deswegen hat
man jetzt festgelegt die beiden
parteichefs werden also ralph brinkhaus
vorschlagen üblich ist es bei der cdu
csu er ist der fraktionsvorsitzende
gemeinsame für ein jahr gewählt wird
jetzt macht man ein unterschied man wird
eine kürzere spanne wählen
offensichtlich ein halbes jahr warum das
ist ganz klar damit sich in der fraktion
erst mal sortiert was passiert wenn wir
doch in die regierung doch noch
irgendwie rein rutschen bzw was passiert
wenn wir höchstwahrscheinlich in die
opposition gehen dann ist diese funktion
des fraktionsvorsitzenden
gleichzeitig natürlich der
oppositionschef hier im deutschen
bundestag extrem viel wichtiger und dann
wird es den einen oder anderen geben der
da ein wörtchen mitreden will und
deswegen ist es vernünftig dass die
beiden parteivorsitzenden sich geeinigt
haben hier einen kompromiss zu finden um
heute den countdown hier sozusagen den
showdown muss ich sagen sozusagen
abzuwenden dennoch hat alexander
dobrindt gesagt werden wir uns hier
genügend zeit nehmen um über die
situation zu diskutieren
der fraktion kann man nicht glücklich
sein über dieses miserable
wahlergebnis 196 abgeordnete sind nur
wiedergekommen
246 abgeordnete waren in der 19
legislaturperiode für cdu/csu hier im
deutschen parlament die csu hat einen
verloren und den rest die cdu und da
sind auch viele persönliche schicksale
bayern natürlich wird man hier heute
eine gemeinsame analyse vorlegen woran
hat es gelegen was können wir in zukunft
ändern und auch über personal dürfte das
eine oder andere gesagt werden
wenngleich der große putsch hier heute
ausbleibt